there are elements of this that exist
not at the human level but at the animal
trial mice level hi i'm dr ayanna howard
i'm the dean of engineering at the ohio
state university i was chair of
interactive computing at georgia tech i
was a robotics researcher at nasa's jpl
today we're going to look at robotic
scenes in movies and judge how real they
are
[Music]
so that actually exists now primarily
it's in the vr ar space which requires
you to
usually have some type of augmented
goggles or device to see the 3d
rendition in the free space and for you
to move around it
[Music]
believe it or not jet packs do exist not
as much control as the actual iron men
but you know has some vertical lift in
the healthcare medical space there are
exoskeletons that provide you i would
say super human ability or capability
and so
pieces of the iron man suit do exist
they aren't as advanced but they all
exist so i would say an 8.5 another
three or four years it would probably be
a 10.
hello i am baymax your personal
healthcare companion oh it's such a cute
movie so unrealistic the only thing that
exists is the fact that you have people
and a robot a form factor everything
else is just imaginary it's what we
would like in our life but we're kind of
far from
even the components of them existing
final yeah going for a non-threatening
huggable kind of thing so soft robotics
does exist soft body robotics is where
you have material that's compliant i
always think of it as a squishy it
actually can apply some forces usually
the focus is on movement they are
considered safe it means you can have
robots working next to people and the
soft
robot wouldn't hurt a person if by some
chance the robot and the human collided
so really it's about safety they aren't
really designed to do things like walk
like a human you are not allergic to
bacitracin you do have a mild allergy to
peanuts i will say in the medical
robotics domain as related to this video
clip there are elements that exist
for example there are systems that can
do diagnosis based on data it can have
an image that looks for things such as
tumors
and sometimes in some cases at more
accuracy or higher accuracy than say a
untrained radiologist so those kind of
things do exist they're usually not
coupled to a moving platform i would
probably rate it about a two
you can now access the cpu central
processing unit is what cpu stands for
the cpu is basically the chip that
powers in this case the mind of the
robot
robot vision is based on cameras the
same kind of cameras you have in your
smartphone
are the same kind of cameras that you
have in robot platforms a lot of
computer vision algorithms use methods
in deep learning to identify objects
identify people even identify facial
expressions of people the red tint
was for entertainment purposes only
rebooting is a thing it's a reality
rebooting includes refreshing your
computer you can do that with a robotic
system it wipes out all its programming
robots like sophia are not as emotive as
a human face the reason is is that the
muscles that we have in our face and the
kind of nuances that we can exhibit in
terms of cheeks and our nose and our
eyes we just don't have the technology
yet at that level i would rate the first
part as a one i would rate the second
part closer to a five
there's a lot of hurdles even creating a
transformer robot there is research in
robotics called origami robotics so they
can fold themselves up they can change
their locomotion style they're typically
very very small my lab actually created
a transformer robot but it was really
really small some of the issues it
really is about stability and control
the fact is is the larger you create the
form factor the more you have to think
about things like gravity you have to
think about weight how do you ensure
that they don't fall over we do not have
sufficient actuation to
lift
the weight that would be required to
create a transformer robot i would rate
this
as a 2.5 i probably would rate it as a
one but i have an affinity for
transformer robots what i really need is
a droid who understands the binary
language of moisture evaporators
evaporators sir my first job was
programming binary load lifters i always
loved how they
showcased robots in star wars because
they
had all of the types of interactions we
expect between human and human and they
encoded in a robot form factor
[Music]
there is actually a number of studies
that have looked at the form factor of
robotics do you have to have a humanoid
shape in order to enhance the
interaction with people most studies
show that you don't it just has to be
able to function and behave and move in
our human environment r2d2 if you think
about the form factor and the shape that
is not what evokes our human
response our human compassion our
empathy for the robot what makes r2d2 so
endearing is a combination of the
movement
so the movements that go on in terms of
doing little dances for example turning
in place the other is the
sounds that are used they're very
intentional if you notice they're
typically high pitched we associate
high-pitched sounds with certain
demographics like birds chirping babies
laughing and so what's going on is that
it's evoking that response of the
cuteness of the sounds coupled with the
movement it's not the form factor it's
the
movements and the language that really
taps into our human emotions so i would
actually put this at a six
so there is a field in robotics called
multi-agent collaboration as well as
this area of collaborative robotics and
in that case there is research that has
shown on the order of hundreds of robots
that collaborate together there's
different approaches some of it is a
centralized approach so there might be a
leader that kind of gives commands and
communicates with all of the team and
then there's also what's called
distributed collaboration distributed
control where every asian every robot
has its own objective function and kind
of communicates as in a team as an
example there are
robot soccer teams that's collaborative
they play together they interact
together
[Music]
small robots like this are possible in
fact there are robots about this size
that can fly you know the size of
bird of a butterfly things like that of
course they don't have as much
functionality as these robots are as
much intelligence as these robots
there's even a field of robotics where
the robots are even smaller nanorobotics
for example there's a robot that is a
pill that you swallow that can actually
do some of the imaging in your
intestines that's a whole
field that requires different types of
tools different types of materials and
in that space you're actually doing
things at the microscope level you're
actually using things like tweezers to
put things together i would rate this
probably at a three
this movie actually defies physics just
some fundamental things about the
interface and the interaction of bodies
and water that just didn't correlate in
this movie
so versatility is a
desired objective but
we typically do not
focus on it because the more versatile
you are the more likely you'll have
failures safety and minimizing failures
to zero is much more important than
having
versatility so for space robotics a lot
of the things that have to be thought
about are about survivability they have
to be able to withstand the radiation of
space the environmental constraints the
extreme temperatures from basically cold
a lot of our space robotics in terms of
the processing power is not even as
advanced as say things are the latest a
smartphone because
they cannot withstand the severity of
the environment in which they're going
into i would rate this a one
there are elements of this that exist
not at the human level but at the animal
trial mice level looking at the spine
and tapping into the electric signals
and trying to use that to control
something the closest that exists in the
domain are really two areas of robotics
research so one is basically using
muscle activation in that case what they
do is that they pair up your muscles
usually in your chest and they pair it
up with electronics to control the arm
and so that's one example the other is
is that there's research where they do
direct implants into the brain so that
they can extract signals from the brain
to control robotic arms i will tell you
both of them are invasive they aren't as
simple as just strapping on something
and automatically you can control
robotics both of these kinds of research
paths require intense surgery these
smart arms are controlled by my brain
through a neural link nanowires feed
directly into my cerebellum allowing me
to use these arms the closest of
controlling robots with your thoughts is
looking at some research that uses eeg
devices or even emg so actually looking
at muscle activation the reality is the
resolution that we can extract in terms
of bits of information
is still very limited it means that if
you're trying to control a robot arm the
most you can kind of think about is like
a joystick i can go up i can go down
left and right but it's very difficult
to do that intentionally over and over
and over again with the resolution that
you would need to fully control a robot
arm especially multiple
arms i would actually rate this as a
four
this case they did design it based on an
actual platform with the way that it
moves the way that it navigates
the sensor that was shown which was most
likely a lidar does exist in a small
platform so lidars for example are in
some of the self-driving cars they are
on a number of mobility platforms in the
warehouse environment and so what they
do is that they create a 3d point cloud
of the environment and they are fairly
robust to things like lighting issues
and convex and concave objects and they
are now at a small enough footprint that
they can fit into
the torso of the robot that we saw
having a robot plug into an electronic
device and magically be able to hack the
code and override any passwords and
encryption scheme is really not feasible
the energy requirements for a robotic
system to continuously activate or
actuate to
do the processing in terms of the
computation to do the sensing
solar power would not provide
the longevity that's required to
actually function for more than a couple
of minutes traditionally you wouldn't
use solar power at least for
this application i would probably rate
this at about a three
detector what are you doing
you said they've all been programmed
with three laws so that means we have 1
000 robots that will not try to protect
themselves if it violates a direct order
from a human isaac asimov created these
three laws of robotics one was thou
shalt not harm a human two was thou
shalt obey a human as long as it doesn't
harm a human basically the concept is is
that robots are here to help us
and therefore they should never be in a
situation where they're not but the fact
is that's never going to happen if you
think about a very simple device such as
a self-driving car which is a robot if
it's autonomous
what do you do if you have your driver
and you're about to crash into something
either you might harm your driver you
might harm the other what are you
supposed to do and so really you can't
actually
follow any of these rules if you're in
the human world
[Music]
is not possible to hurl a human exactly
the way that the robot hurled will smith
but
the reason why
robots in industrial settings typically
do not work with humans if a robot is
moving and a human is in the way the
human will be hurled we are soft bodies
that don't do well when we
interact with metal that's moving that
fast
what am i hoping
let's take away the intelligence if you
look at the actuation and the mobility
we do have something boston dynamic with
petman actually does parkour does flips
does turns in mid-air gymnastics
that platform does exist now of course
power requirements it doesn't last that
long it won't survive in the real world
for hours like we would need but the
actuation does exist the intelligence
part though
is not coupled with the movement part i
re-rate it as a three why don't we start
with you telling me something about
yourself
well
you already know my name
and you can see that i'm a machine
the turing test was a test that was
created to really try to figure out how
do you know when a computer is
intelligent
and so the concept is that if you had an
individual that asks questions of a
computer and of a person if the person
who was asking the questions could not
tell the difference between
computer and person i.e mislabeled then
the computer had passed the turing test
the problem of course is that it's the
observer who is saying oh i can't tell
the difference so the turing test has
been quote unquote beaten all of the
time
because it's based on the observer point
of view and is based on the questions
that you ask when did you learn how to
speak ava
i always knew how to speak
and that's strange
isn't it
you know a lot of times we're thinking
about a language model
it takes hours and hours and sometimes
days depending in order to come up with
the ability to have a conversation
and so the fact that she very easily on
the order of milliseconds could acquire
new knowledge could actually
understand new nuances to the questions
that were asked is actually not a
realistic
aspect of our current state of art i
would rate this as a 2.5
both my favorite and the best depiction
i would say is the iron man
video clip if you enjoyed this video
click the link above